the episode opens up in the city of
pretty Lake where we are introduced to
two college students Adam and Wiley
though Wiley is only 19 years old she is
pregnant and does not want to reveal the
father of the baby later in the evening
she is in church where her dad and
sister work suddenly a scream is heard
and unchecking they find their dad lying
dead on the floor with blood all over
his mouth the sisters are left in utter
disbelief at how a healthy person like
their dad can pass away in this manner
the next day some more people die in the
same fashion by vomiting huge amounts of
blood the scene then fast forwards to
the fourth day since the incidents began
and now about 50 people have already
lost their lives due to the horrific
nature of the deaths the Ministers of
pretty Lake assume that a contagious
disease has been spread and hence they
decide to initiate a quarantine soon
meanwhile Adam visits his uncle at the
morgue who happens to be a scientist he
is studying the blood samples of the
deceased citizens to try and figure out
what caused the outbreak but even after
hours of research nothing conclusive has
come up it's almost as if the people
died without any abnormalities worried
Adam returns home and urges his mother
that they should leave the city
immediately however before she can say a
word Blood starts coming out of her
mouth and she too dies a painful death
the entire city is surrounded by Army
officials who put an electric fence
along the city boundaries following this
we are introduced to the other
protagonists of the show The creaker
Brothers the Elder one is Pat who is
responsible and hard-working while the
younger one Ronnie is a drug dealer who
often gets into altercations a few days
later as the city continues to spiral
out of control because of the rapid
deaths and the strict quarantine the
creaker brothers decide to have some fun
they break into the vehicle showroom of
the richest man in the city Charles and
drive away in one of his expensive
trucks however the cunning businessman
notices them via CCTV and decides to
take matters into his own hands he along
with his equally arrogant son Chuck fall
follow the creaker brothers and
eventually Corner them on an isolated
Road Charles then brings out his rifle
and forces them to strip down but before
he can proceed with his other devious
plans a Good Samaritan by the name of
gourd arrives there with a gun and
forces Charles to let the brothers go
stop using your rifle to look at bare
ass Charles elsewhere Adam being a
genius student hacks into the government
website and learns that no one under 22
years old has died from the unknown
disease shocked he rushes to the morgue
to inform his uncle about it but finds
him dead on the floor later he meets his
best friend Wiley and tells her that
something unusual is going around so
they should leave the city immediately
Wiley agrees to run away and starts
packing her belongings unfortunately a
few hours later her water breaks leaving
her unable to walk so she messages Adam
and informs him that she can't come
seeing Wiley in excruciating pain her
sister Melissa tries calling a doctor
but due to the chaos outside no one
responds hence she rushes to the Good
Samaritan from early player Gord who
also happens to be her good friend and
asks him for help the two of them then
head over to Wiley and assist her in
delivering a baby boy on the other hand
Adam reaches the border of the city
holding a fence cutter unfortunately he
gets spotted by the army officers who
open fire on him Adam gets hit by one of
the bullets but is saved by the
bulletproof jacket he is wearing four
days pass by but the situation shows no
signs of improvement the government has
still not made any breakthrough about
what caused the outbreak with all the
people above the age of 22 dead Melissa
starts looking after the orphans at the
church one day the government announces
that the virus is starting to slow down
and the quarantine will soon be lifted
but for that the young citizens will
have to gather and burn all the dead
bodies the news gives hope to the
remaining citizens and they immediately
begin Gathering the dead bodies at a
designated spot in the meantime Chuck
has become somewhat of a leader after
his arrogant Father Charles passed away
he is trying to control the Youth of the
city so that they don't cause any Mayhem
at least his dad's not around around to
look at their butts anymore he is also
desperately searching for his lost
sister Lana who has been missing for a
couple of days at one time he and the
boys catch the aggressive drug dealer
Ronnie Krieger stealing medications from
a house Chuck tries to take control of
the situation and warns Ronnie to step
back but the latter just won't listen
instead he brings out his gun and
threatens to shoot the boys if they keep
standing in his way left with no choice
Chuck lets him go however in the evening
when one of the pals shows him an image
of a woman with her middle finger cut
off shock loses his cool he recognizes
the woman is the owner of the same house
from which Ronnie stole the medication
and deduces that he did it to steal her
ring hence he gathers his colleagues and
heads to Ronnie's place for revenge in
the next scene we see Wiley barging into
somebody's house presumably the father
of her child and searching for something
right then a boy walks up to her holding
a knife scared Wiley mentions that she
will leave but he stops her and asks her
to stay with him he even opens a safe
for her and finds an envelope inside
with her name on it but before you can
hand it over to her Wiley feels dizzy
and collapses to the floor elsewhere as
Gord is working on his farm he notices a
flock of vultures circling over
something in the nearby Forest curious
he walks to the place only to find
Chuck's sister Lana dead near a tree she
has a revolver in her hand and a wound
on her head guess she just couldn't
stand her dad looking at children's
butts anymore without wasting any time
he calls Chuck and Adam to the scene the
latter takes a look around the place and
deduces that someone tussled with her
before she passed away he also takes
pictures of the crime scene along with a
footprint beside the dead body with a
heavy heart Chuck then picks up his
sister's body and burns it after
bringing it to their backyard that
evening Chuck's other sister Amanda who
is suffering from autism tries to
prepare some chicken burgers and fries
at their grocery store the little girl
believes that her sister Lana will soon
return home however because of her
clumsiness the oil catches fire and a
large portion of the star is burned
Amanda is thankfully unharmed but she is
too scared to reveal it was her fault
hence when her brother inquires about
what happened she lies that she saw an
old truck entering the store hearing
this Chuck deduces that the creaker
brothers are responsible for it as they
too have an old truck those goddamn
creakers are at it again later at night
the whole city gathers around the pile
of dead bodies and prepares to set them
on fire at the same time Adam is looking
for a person whom he found on the
government website Because he believes
that he has some information about the
mysterious disease luckily he finds the
man and takes something out of his
pocket but as he prepares to leave he
hears somebody coughing nearby on a
closer look Adam is stunned to see Wiley
among the dead bodies he quickly
approaches her and carries her out right
before the entire pile is burned to a
crisp meanwhile a tiger escapes from the
zoo after attacking a little boy who
would come there to feed him that was
random geez the next morning Chuck finds
Elana's cell phone and goes straight to
gourd he asserts that they need to
confront the creaker brothers and teach
them a lesson about first gourd
hesitates claiming that they can't just
go around attacking people but when he
gets to know that Ronnie was the last
person who messaged Lana he agrees to
join shock before leaving the farm Gord
asks his little sister Francis to take
care of the cows and feed them next
Chuck along with Gord and his friends
surround the creaker brothers house at
night and demand Ronnie come out worried
the elder brother Pat tells Ronnie to
hide in the basement while he handles
the situation he then walks out of the
house and starts talking to Gordon chalk
suddenly the electricity in the entire
town goes out making Chuck believe that
the creaker brothers are trying to trap
them hence he opens fire on Pat
prompting Ronnie to fire back from the
basement when the situation almost gets
out of control Chuck and his group
decide to retreat but while doing so
Gord gets hit by a bullet later Chuck
stops his truck at a pharmacy and drops
Gord off there the latter reassures that
he's fine and can look after himself but
after Chuck leaves Gord enters the store
and falls to the ground due to the
severe loss of blood fortunately his
friend Melissa arrived lives there and
helps him back to his feet she also
cleans his wound and stitches it at the
same time Tracy the other creaker
sibling informs Pat that Ronnie has left
the house she also reveals that she
checked his phone and found text
messages sent to Lana and another girl
meanwhile Ronnie can be seen creeping
into Chuck's house where his girlfriend
Stacy is sleeping it appears as if the
two have known each other for a long
time and share a close Bond Ronnie
continuously asks for help claiming that
he didn't kill Lana and Stacy decides to
help him the following morning she takes
him to meet shock and help him settle
their differences however at the very
last moment she betrays Ronnie and lies
to Chuck that she was being attacked
enraged Chuck along with his boys run
after Ronnie to beat him up on the other
hand gord's sister Francis is trying to
turn on the generator to power the farm
to her bad luck the escaped tiger
arrives before her forcing her to run
into the attic later she holds a gun and
slowly comes out of hiding the tiger
notices her and starts approaching her
but in the nick of time she fires off a
few shots and finishes it off elsewhere
Adam and Wiley decide to take advantage
of the power outage to escape the city
as now only a few army officers are
guarding the electric fence before
leaving she takes a look at her baby and
leaves him in the care of Melissa after
a while they reach the border and
successfully tear open the fence using a
cutter surprisingly when they walk past
the fence they noticed that the area
around them is covered with landmines in
order to check Adam throws Wiley's bag
to the ground and as they had expected a
large explosion ensues the bag is
completely destroyed and a large amount
of cash is flying around why didn't you
throw your shoe you idiot Adam asks
Wiley where she got the money but she
refuses to answer with their failed
attempt the two then returned back to
their City somewhere else Ronnie is
holding a man to hostage when Chuck and
his boys find him worried about the
Mayhem that she has caused the little
girl finally admits that she was the one
who set the supermarket on fire at the
same time Ronnie also tells Chuck that
he didn't kill Lana and asks for a gun
in return for Amanda's safety having no
option he reluctantly provides him with
a rifle and rescues his sister and
before Ronnie can make a move Chuck
attacks him and punches him in the face
multiple times right then Gord and Pat
arrive at the scene and separate them
they then reveal that Ronnie was
actually with Chuck's girlfriend Stacy
when Lana got killed Ronnie then walks
away from there stating that the fight
has just begun in the next scene Gord
returns to his Farmhouse and becomes
terrified after seeing a dead tiger in
the front yard he immediately goes
inside and begins searching for Francis
moments later he finds her and mentions
that their parents would be very proud
of The Bravery that she has shown today
on the other hand when Wiley returns
home Melissa yells at her for leaving
her child and walking away without
informing her hearing this Wiley becomes
angry and exits the house but not before
informing her sister that she doesn't
have to look after her baby boy anymore
later while Wiley is wandering around
the city she meets Ronnie he tells her
that she can stop by his place if she
wants and surprisingly Wiley agrees to
go with him the next morning the you
head to the woods to hunt leaving her
little boy in the care of Tracy
elsewhere in town two young kids
Harrison and his friend break into
Chuck's car warehouse and drive away in
an expensive black car outside Chuck's
boys noticed the robbery and start
chasing them moments later Harrison
loses control of the car and crashes it
into a ditch he and his friend try to
run away from the scene but get caught
by Chuck's boys later they are brought
to Chuck who decides to punish them
unless they come up with a good apology
however Harrison does not apologize and
instead berates Chuck for acting as if
he is the head of the state this enrages
the latter so he ties Harris into a
metal pole meanwhile Adam again visits
the place in the forest where Lana's
body was found before he looks around
and discovers a cap similar to what Pat
creeker used to wear during baseball
games with this information Adam decides
to investigate the case himself later he
secretly heads to the creaker residence
and takes a look at the boots kept
outside surprisingly the prince on the
back of the boots match the ones in the
picture Adam then tries investigating
more but right then Tracy notices him
and inquires about what he's doing there
to escape the situation Adam lies that
he's simply looking for Ronnie to get
some drugs elsewhere Wiley can be seen
enjoying her time with Ronnie after
drinking a few beers he tries to make
out with her but Wiley makes it clear
that she is not interested in him
despite this Ronnie does not stop and
keeps forcing himself luckily Tracy
arrives there in time and hits him with
a spade providing Wiley enough time to
escape later at night Pat meets up with
Adam and tells him that he didn't kill
Lana but he tried to stop her from
committing the unthinkable this explains
why there were signs of struggle near
the place where she died he then hands
out him a note and prepares to leave
just then Chuck arrives there with his
boys and starts shooting at Pat the
latter somehow manages to escape and
before Chuck can go after him Adam
intervenes he claims that Pat is
innocent because Lana had actually
committed the unthinkable to verify his
claim he hands Chuck his sister's last
note that Pat gave him earlier Chuck is
devastated by the Revelation and to make
matters worse he is informed that the
boy he tied to a pole earlier Harrison
has become unconscious it turns out that
the boy is diabetic and he has gone into
an insulin shock luckily some people
arrive at the scene and successfully
manage to resuscitate the boy back at
the house Pat talks with Tracy and gets
to know about their brother's recent
Shenanigans he berates Ronnie and warns
him to not do it again or else there
will be consequences after some time
Wiley approaches Pat and asks him to
drop her near the city however he
refuses stating that Chuck and his boys
are looking for him in the final scene
while Adam is talking to one of his
teachers the power comes back into the
City and everyone becomes elated
unfortunately the teacher who just
turned 22 starts vomiting blood and dies
on the spot subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching